and i wonder what the impact is of the
language that you bring to the table
so you mentioned about god or um
speaking of god a lot of people are
really interested in theoretical physics
these days at a very surface level
and you can bring the language of
physics right you can talk about quantum
mechanics
you can talk about general general
relativity and
curvature space time and using just that
language
without a deep technical understanding
of it to somehow
start thinking like sort of visualizing
atoms in your head
and somehow through that process because
you have the language
using that language to kind of dissolve
the ego
like realize like that we're just all
little bits
of physical objects that behave in
mysterious ways
and so that that has to do with the
language like if you read a sean carroll
book or something recently
it seems like as a huge influence on the
way you
might experience my perceive the world i
might experience
the alteration that psychedelics brings
to the um to the your perception system
so i wonder like the language you bring
to the table how that affects
the journey you go on with the
psychedelics i think
very much so and and i think there's i'm
a little concerned some of the science
is going a little too far in the
direction of
of around the edges you know speaking
about
it changing beliefs in this sense or
that sense
about particular in particular domains
and i think what really what
a lot of what's going on is what you
just discussed it's it's the priors
coming into
into it so if you've been reading a lot
of you know um
physics then you might you know um
bring up you know like you know
space-time and interpret the experience
in that sense i mean it's not uncommon
for people come out talking about
visions of the
it's not the most typical thing but it's
come up in sessions i've i've guided um
the big bang um and the
you know this sort of nature of reality
i i think probably the the best way to
think about these
experiences is that and the best
evidence even though we're in our
infancy and understanding it
they they really tap into more general
psychological mechanisms
i think one of the best arguments is
they they they
they reduce the influence of the of our
priors
of what we bring into the all of the
assumptions that we all that
you know we're essentially especially as
adults we're riding on top of heuristic
after heuristic to get through life
and you need to do that and that's a
good thing and that's extremely
efficient and evolution has shaped that
but that comes at an expense and i
it seems that these experiences
will will allow someone greater
mental flexibility and openness and so
one can be both less
influenced by their their prior
assumptions but still nonetheless
the nature of the experience can be
influenced by what they've been exposed
to
in the world and sometimes they can get
it at a deeper in a deeper way
like maybe they've read i mean i had a
philosophy professor one time
as a participant yeah in a high-dose
psilocybin study and he's like
i remember him saying my god it's like
hegel's
opposites defining each other like i get
it i've taught this thing
for years and years and years like i get
it now
and so like that you know and and even
at the
psychological emotional level like the
cancer patients um we worked with
you know they told themselves a million
times or this people trying to quit
smoking i need to quit smoking oh i'm
ruining my life with this cancer i'm
still healthy i should be getting out
i'm letting this thing defeat me
it's like yeah you told yourself that in
your head but sometimes they have these
experiences
and they kind of feel it in their heart
like they really get it
you